bonjour et bienvenue au parlement
européen à strasbourg nous sommes
ensemble pour 30 minutes d'actualité
européenne
cette semaine nous vous proposons une
enquête exceptionnelle le trafic d'êtres
humains se développe au coeur même de
l'europe reportage en albanie où nous
avons suivi des associations épaulé par
l'union européenne elle tente de venir
en aide aux jeunes victimes de ce trafic
mais d'abord l'actualité de la semaine
alors que la roumanie et la bulgarie se
sont une nouvelle fois vu refuser
l'entrée dans l'espace schengen ces
négociations ne vient-elle pas au bal
des hypocrites
quelle déception
une nouvelle fois on claque la porte de
schengen en est de la bulgarie et de la
roumanie
mais il fallait s'y attendre non depuis
le temps que ces deux pays de l'est
tambourine à la porte de l'espace et
qu'on leur refuse l'accès au saint graal
pourtant la commission et le parlement
européens estimaient que sofia et
bucarest avait rempli le cahier des
charges que techniquement ils pouvaient
prétendre à devenir les 23e et 24e pays
de la zone
mais non les ministres de l'intérieur de
pays membres n'ont pas voulu entre
autres l'allemagne et les pays-bas pas à
la hauteur des roumains et les bulgares
trop corruptible doté d'un système
judiciaire défaillant pas capables de
contrôler les frontières extérieures pas
apte à juguler l'exode de sa population
vers l'eldorado à l'ouest un peu sévère
non alors cet espace schengen le bal des
hypocrites
et nous voilà de retour sur le plateau
d' europe hebdo au parlement européen à
strasbourg pour évoquer cette question
des frontières extérieures de l'europe
et donc de l'espace schengen nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau sylvie guillaume
bonjour bonjour vous êtes donc membre de
la commission justice et affaires
intérieures entre autres libertés
civiles pardon et justice et vice
présidente du groupe socialiste et
démocrate
alors est-ce que cet espace schengen
finalement c'est pas un petit peu le bal
des hypocrites
c'est une bonne formule effectivement en
tout cas c'est de l'hypocrisie et la
recherche de boucs émissaires et on
assume pas certain nombre de décisions
et c'est ça qui se passe effectivement
en ce moment c'est c'est bien l'idée
générale de l'hypocrisie d'un certain
nombre d'états membres qui considère que
finalement il y à des états de première
ou de deuxième classe dans l'union donc
pour appeler un petit peu le contexte à
nos téléspectateurs
en 2007 la rue mène la roumanie pardon
et la bulgarie entre dans l'union avec
l'idée derrière d'adhérer à l'espace
schengen sauf que depuis finalement on
leur a retoqué la porte presque vingt
trois fois de mémoire dont une très
récemment endormi très récemment jusqu'à
quand ça va durer ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que dans l'intervalle depuis 2007
où on pouvait considérer à juste titre
wpt a move éthique que les deux états
n'étaient pas prêts ils ont fait des
efforts extrêmement sérieux pour se
mettre à jour via les critères qui ont
été demandés à tous les états au moment
d'entrer dans schengen et donc ces états
ont modernisé leurs systèmes de
surveillance ils ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour se mettre à jour
technologiquement
ils sont même d'ailleurs probablement
plus tard mais technologiquement si le
matériel faisait l'ensemble de la
décision ils sont plus armés que
certains autres états ce qui coince
maintenant c'est qu'effectivement sur
fond de crise économique avec des
mouvements de population un certain
nombre d'états considèrent qu'ils ne
sont pas encore prêts et remettre des
étapes supplémentaires à la roumanie et
à la bulgarie
comme si ça ne suffisait pas moi je
considère et le parlement dans son
ensemble a considéré que la bulgarie et
la roumanie vis-à-vis des critères qui
leur était demandé
ont répandu à ce qui leur était ce qui
était nécessaire pour entrer dans
l'espace schengen donc il ya d'autres
raisons et c'est pour ça que vous aviez
raison de dire que c'est de l'hypocrisie
donc là la raison effectivement vous
l'avez évoqué c'est la possibilité d'une
j'ouvre les guillemets d'une invasion
puisque ce sont les termes qui ont été
utilisés notamment par les britanniques
par la presse britannique entre autres
d'une invasion de roumains et de
bulgares sur l'europe de l'ouest est ce
que c'est un risque finalement est-ce
que c'est pas déjà le cas vu que les
roumains et les bulgares ont déjà la
liberté de circulation
et justement ça n'est pas tout à fait ça
la situation ce qui est reproché à
priori à ces deux états qui sont en
bordure de l'union européenne c'est
d'avoir des frontières extérieures trop
poreuse et de ne pas savoir faire la
police aux frontières de l'union
et donc de laisser rentrer défi des gens
de manière clandestine dans l'union
s'est pas tellement là l'entrée des
bulgares et des roumains dans le reste
de l'union parce qu'effectivement la
libre circulation exista n'est pas la
problématique c'est d'autres types de
plus emblématiques plus exactement mais
c'est en gros ce qui est ce qui pose
problème un certain nombre d'états
membres
c'est le fait que la bulgarie et la
roumanie n'ont pas ne sont pas
suffisamment sérieuse
d'une part dans la corruption et d'autre
part dans la porosité de leurs
frontières et cette porosité de
frontières c'est aussi la sphère de
toute l'europe on ne peut pas juger
demandé aux bulgares aux roumains aux
grecs ou aux turcs de s'occuper des
frontières de l'europe
sauf que les frontières sont plus ou
moins poreuse et plus ou moins
dangereuses a traversé l'europe a bouclé
les entrées en méditerranée qu'il
s'agisse de l'entrée par l'espagne puis
par la méditerranée il ya eu l'année
dernière et c'est aussi un sujet avec
les printemps arabes l'arrivée à
lampedusa et donc de réaction de
monsieur berlusconi et sarkozy qui ont
posé des problématiques visas schengen
et puis les barrières à l'entrée
ce sont des portages jusqu'à la grèce
qui reste maintenant
le principal le bleu d'entrée de l'union
mais demain si effectivement la bulgarie
et la roumanie rentrer dans schengen
s'ouvre de nouvelles frontières
extérieures de l'union qui peuvent
éventuellement permettre l'entrée sur le
territoire schengen donc c'est ça qui
pose problème à ses états membres
alors vous l'avez évoqué silvio
berlusconi à nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
avait voulu remettre en question donc
les frontières extérieures et l'entrée
de certains pays dans schengen
on voit finalement que malgré l'arrivée
de françois hollande au pouvoir la
position de la france n'a pas évolué sur
cette question vous en tant que
socialiste est ce que vous en pensez
ce que nicolas sarkozy et silvio
berlusconi avait mis en cause s'étaient
pas les frontières extérieures s'était
il voulait avoir de nouvelles règles
pour l'entrée et donc qu'ils avaient
érigées de leur propre fait de nouvelles
règles prétextant un afflux après les
printemps à il avait voulu aussi à un
moment remettre en question les spatiaux
niel exactement parce par ce biais là en
remettant des frontières là où il n'y
avait pas lieu d'être et où ils ne
pouvaient pas décider seul
la situation est très différente
maintenant dans la position de l'état
français puisque les dernières
rencontres entre monsieur comptable
premier ministre roumain et avec le
premier ministre français ont montré
qu'il y avait une évolution possible sur
la question de l'entrée la roumanie et
la bulgarie dont je crois qu'on
progresse
il faut faire les choses dans un bon
calendrier avec de bonnes résolutions
mais je crois que les choses progressent
en tout cas c'est selon vous c'est pas
assez au sens où les propositions qui
ont été faites à la roumanie et à la
bulgarie ne sont pas ne sont pas correct
du point de vue des critères demandés à
certains jeux de dupes finalement on a
remis un petit peu de nouvelles règles
au milieu de la côte de la baie de la
partie de foot si je puis dire
d'où l'idée effectivement et j'espère
qu'on pourra du point de vue des
autorités françaises être vraiment sûr
ces règles de droit de remettre
exactement les bons critères c'est ce
que vous demandez à françois hollande et
au premier je pense qu'ils sont dans
cette perspective là c'est en tout cas
ce qui est prévu de discuter dans le
prochain conseil jaye donc on aura
sûrement des éléments complémentaires à
ce moment là il ya une autre question
qui intéresse sur schengen en ce moment
c'est la cécilia maelström qui l'a mise
à l'agenda c'est la question des
frontières internes
entre guillemets l'idée ce serait de
faire un espèce de passeports
biométriques ou une carte biométrique
pour les visiteurs qui viendrait de
l'extérieur de l'europe en europe
les verts y voient une forme de big
brother 2.0 est ce que c'est votre avis
oui c'est un aspect des choses et vous
savez que globalement la question des
données et des passages des frontières
avec la biométrie est un problème en soi
moi ce que je trouve aussi un autre
aspect de la question que je trouve
assez problématique aussi c'est ce sont
des frontières intelligente pour les
gens riches et bien portants n'est
certes pas de manière
et moi j'ai tout à fait consciente que
faciliter le passage des hommes
d'affaires des étudiants qui font
beaucoup de trajets qui font beaucoup
d'allers-retours est une problématique
en soi qui doit être résolu et pourquoi
pas facilité les choses de ce point de
vue ça ne les vend rien une réflexion
plus large sur la manière dont l'europe
accueille ou pas ou quelles sont les
règles pour le reste des gens qui
migrent et là ça fait là aussi deux
classes différentes
en gros vous pointez une europe à deux
vitesses une nouvelle fois bon bah
écoute et merci beaucoup en attendant
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
nous on continue sur les questions des
frontières mais cette fois-ci de la zone
euro bizarrement alors que la zone euro
est en pleine crise la lettonie vient de
faire acte de candidature on en parle
tout de suite avec aurélie da face au
travers du zapping des télévisions
étrangères
un dix-huitième pays dans la zone euro
l'idée fait son chemin depuis déjà
quelques temps jean ping wei wu à wigan
shopping au marché central de riga tout
est payé en lattes
mais la monnaie pourrait bientôt changer
pour l'euro après avoir expérimenté
l'une des pires récessions en europe
l'économie lettone se redresse et biz
maintenant à rejoindre la zone euro un
dôme sera regretté jean de gaulle
faisait alors attractive l'eurozone les
députés européens les tons semblent
divisés sur la question
je suis totalement pour il ya plusieurs
raisons à cela d'abord nous sommes
profondément intégré en europe
nos exportations vers l'europe
représente environ 77 je ne pense pas
que ce soit le moment d'adhérer à la
zone euro à pleine crise nous devons
attendre au moins
2014 interros tous à emporter la
décision relève maintenant de la
commission européenne réponse en juillet
mais déjà c'est experts expriment un
avis positif
la lettonie a fait des progrès
significatifs pour ajuster son économie
revenir en tête parmi les états membres
être compétitive donc je pense que
probablement en termes de critères
les chances sont très bonnes pour que la
commission délivre un verdict positif
cette année et pour évoquer cette
possible entrée de la lettonie dans la
zone euro c'est jean sébastien lefebvre
qui nous a rejoint bonjour vous êtes
journaliste à euractiv un portail
d'information sur l'actualité européenne
alors c'est assez étonnant parce que la
lettonie est un pays en crise on pensait
que c'est un pays en crise pourquoi est
ce qu'elles demandent son adhésion à la
zone euro à la lettonie était un pays en
crise en 2008 ce moment de la crise des
subprimes en fait l'économie s'est
écroulé elle a perdu 21 % de son pib qui
équivaut à peu près ce qu'a perdu la
grèce en mai en six mois six mois un an
aujourd'hui elle va beaucoup mieux 5 %
de croissance
un chiffre dans tout le monde réel
exactement mais bon elle repart elle
part de loin finalement on peut dire ça
et du coup aujourd'hui l'ambition des
politiques lettons et deux d'entre eux
dans la zone euro mais ç'a toujours été
le cas finalement avant la crise ils
voulaient aussi intégré c'est une forme
de fixette chez eux et depuis très
longtemps déjà le cours de la monnaie
lettone est indexé sur l'euro est bloqué
donc ça veut dire que le il ya une
parité fixe et laure l'adhésion en fait
de la lettonie ils ont toujours eu ce
but en tête en tête c'est dans les
traités de façon ils doivent à terme y
rentrer mais c'est vraiment un objectif
prioritaire chez eux et même durant la
crise de 2008 ils n'ont pas touché la
parité de la monnaie
ça veut dire que ils ont préféré couper
dans les salaires faire des coups faire
de l'austérité plutôt que d'évaluer la
monnaie ou faire des choses comme ça
donc c'est vraiment un objectif à terme
est ce qui est assez étonnant c'est que
alors que la zone euro finalement est en
crise
on a un pays qui cherche un petit peu
quoi c'est une protection finalement
d'entrer dans cette dans cette zone
les partisans pour 10
de toute façon déjà très intégré ça peut
qu'être bénéfique pour la lettonie
d'avoir des échanges facilités avec la
zone euro effectivement et après on peut
voir dans l'imaginaire letton aussi un
attachement très fort à l'europe par
rapport à son voisin russe donc c'est
une sorte d' ancrage définitif au sein
de l'union européenne
est ce que d'autres pays comme la
lettonie qui sont dans la même et des
halles à l'estonie qui a rentré
dernièrement aussi c'était en 2012
le la lituanie veut suivre donc les
trois pays baltes finalement veulent
toujours rentrée et puis à la pologne
qui commence à réfléchir
mais la pologne c'est à la fois quelque
chose d'économique mais aussi politique
c'est la pologne ne veut pas être mise à
la marge de l'union européenne donc elle
dit si on veut continuer à être au coeur
de l'intégration européenne il faut
qu'on rejoigne la zone euro donc il ya
un débat qui commence à se lancer avec
le premier ministre donald tusk qui dit
il faut qu'on faut qu'on y aille
ils savent pas quand ils sont encore un
peu prudent mais la pologne à terme
barbare les années et pour la lettonie
qu'est ce qu'on pense les institutions
européennes est ce qu'on peut quel est
le calendrier finalement de 7 alors là
il faut que la banque centrale
européenne et la commission européenne
analyse la situation en lettonie mais si
on prend un rapport qui a été publié en
mai 2012 par la commission européenne
on voit qu'elle est quand même un petit
peu sceptique en disant tous les
critères ne sont pas là niveau
endettement ça va la dette publique
c'est 40 % du pib donc ça c'est en
dessous des critères de maastricht se
pose la question de la fassions la
stabilité des prix
ça c'est pas très clair donc il va
falloir attendre mais les lettons sont
très optimistes quand on écoute les
ministres le premier ministre il c'est
sûr ils vont en avoir il favorable ils
vont entrer en 2014 et c'est donc là ça
va ça va être après les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement de la zone euro qui à la
fin devant donner leur aval donc ça
reste une décision politique il faut se
rappeler que la grèce est rentrée dans
la zone euro en 2000
vite donc la gué source ai voit la foule
non il faut bien faire attention à qui
rompt avec les mécanismes de contrôle y
voilà alors justement vous parlez de la
grèce on a la dent au temps forts de
l'actualité on parle budget en parle pas
qu on peut la crise alors est-ce qu'on
est sortis d'affaires finalement ça
dépend laquelle de crise en fait la
crise financière on a même pour
l'instant est en sommeil
les marchés sont à peu près calme on a
eu quelques soubresauts avec les
élections en italie et dans l'ensemble
ça va à peu près aujourd'hui la crise a
en quelque sorte est descendu d'un étage
elle n'est plus financière l es
économique et social on voit que le
chômage continue à augmenter les
perspectives de croissance ne sont pas
réjouissantes pour les deux années à
venir
donc finalement la crise et hélas sauf
qu'elle est beaucoup plus diffuse on a
pu les temps forts de l'automne 2011 et
de l'hiver 2012 mais elle est finalement
dans le quotidien de tous les européens
et dernière question rapidement on voit
que l'impasse politique en italie joue
peut-être un petit peu sur les marchés
la france vient d'annoncer qu'elle ne
respecterait pas les 3% de déficit
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un effet
rebond de cette crise du coup ses skis
certains pensent après faut savoir est
ce que la crise en italie va perdurer
est ce que finalement les députés de
pépé griot vont pas fuit accepté de
voter la confiance pour un gouvernement
de gauche
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes donc le
fait que la france respecte pas le
déficit à 3% cette année devrait pas
avoir forcément beaucoup de conséquences
c'est même la commission est quand même
assez souple on a vu que olli rehn
il ya un mois quand il a fait des
prévisions de croissance en trois
semaines a dit que bout ils vont ils
vont pas les sanctionner tout de suite
peut-être empruntant mais on verra et
finalement plutôt en allemand la france
s'en sort pas si mal
voilà et puis plus tôt en 2014 parce que
bon si on coupe encore dans les dépenses
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer au point de
vue de la croissance où ça va être
encore pire la commission commence
finalement à se poser en interne
l'intérieur des questions sur est-ce que
l'austérité forcément la réponse à tout
merci jean sébastien le fait d'avoir été
parmi nous pour nous expliquer tout ça
nous on continue notre voyage direction
l'albanie à tirana plus exactement si ce
pays ne fait pas partie de l'union
européenne il obtient des fonds
notamment pour lutter contre la traite
des êtres humains avant de retrouver
kathia gilder et son invité direction
tirana avec fabrice qu'une haie et miné
alayli estelle voit l'eau
chico vaut mieux qu ils ne mangeraient
pour noël
que ce soit les champs c'est la dernière
campagne d'une ong albanaise contre la
traite des êtres humains le dernier
symbole de la mobilisation contre ces
trafics ici en albanie l'exploitation
des enfants ou la prostitution ont
longtemps été des sujets tabous et un
problème récurrent dans un pays où le
salaire moyen ne dépasse pas 200 euros
par mois
depuis quelques années les choses
changent et la lutte contre ces trafics
s'organise depuis son petit bureau de la
capitale tirana
daniela coordonne l'action des ong
dédiée à l'enfance un vaste réseau
d'alerté dead à la réinsertion parti
d'un constat
ici il n'y a pas de service public qui
aide les enfants difficultés à se
réinsérer
c'est à nous à alger d'assurer cette
mission il faut réintégrer ces jeunes
victimes de violences de trafic ou de
travaux forcés et comme l'état ne le
fait pas notre travail est très
important dans leur travail au quotidien
les ong mettent l'accent sur la
prévention exemple dans cet immeuble au
coeur d'un quartier très défavorisé de
tirana un accueil de jour pour des
enfants en grande précarité et un
soutien pour leurs familles les enfants
qu'à être on a appris aujourd'hui
chaque jour une cinquantaine d'enfants
déscolarisés se retrouvent autour de ces
tables pour des cours ou des activités
une alternative à la rue ce sont pour la
plupart des enfants livrés à eux mêmes
et qui vivent dans une grande pauvreté
ils sont tous des victimes potentielles
de n'importe quel trafic ou souvent
utilisés par leurs familles pour gagner
de l'argent
il s'appelle beyram berti ou franco ils
ont entre 4 et 15 ans tous racontent la
même histoire les mêmes difficultés
familiales et travaille et fait partie
de leur quotidien
moi je vends des noisettes aux gens et
après je donne l'argent à un moment
quand on rentre à la maison
moi quand je suis dehors je cherche du
fer où je vais sur internet et le faire
que je trouve
je le vends pour ma famille
eux sont restés à tirana mais parfois
les enfants seraient loués ou envoyés au
kosovo en macédoine en grèce pour
travailler quelqu'un a vu la maîtrise
ioana pour sony la masse ati certains
réseaux criminels cible les familles
pauvres et profite de ce trafic
après plusieurs années à la direction de
ce centre d'accueil
elle voit la situation s'améliorait
lentement je pense qu'il reste beaucoup
de difficultés il y à certaines
problématiques que l'on n'arrive
toujours pas à résoudre à cause de la
bureaucratie
même s'il est à adopter des lois
récemment le chemin est encore long pour
que l'on réussisse ensemble à trouver
des réponses aux problèmes de ses
enfants et de leurs familles
sous la pression de l'union européenne
l'albanie a en effet adopté une série de
lois mises en place des plans d'actions
depuis une dizaine d'années pour lutter
contre le trafic d'êtres humains
l'homme clé du dispositif le vice
ministre de l'intérieur
face aux critiques ne redonne d'oka
réclame du temps la coopération avec les
ong c'est vrai et à améliorer pour
réinsérer les victimes dans la société
il faut aussi que l'on perfectionne
notre cadre juridique
même si le cadre existant me semble déjà
efficace on doit travailler à l'adapter
aux standards européens et ses carences
sont encore plus criants en matière de
prostitution
c'est du moins le constat fait par les
ong comme celle d'ariel à mitry les
femmes sont victimes de stigmatisation
par la société albanaise et les
structures de réintégration manque
seulement 5 sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour des raisons de sécurité impossible
de filmer ses centres d'accueil pour
fait leur intégration au début les
victimes mais sans lui besoin d'une
maison d'une place pour de mieux la
sécurité pour la nourriture et après
construit un projet de réintégration
et si toujours c'est difficile trouver
une place que ce soit pour les enfants
ou pour les femmes victimes de trafic
la solution passe par l'éducation
l'europe soutient certains programmes de
sensibilisation à tirana comme dans le
reste de l'albanie mais dans un pays où
l'on manque de tout les trafiquants ont
encore une longueur d'avancé
c'est incroyable mais c'est bien la
réalité vous l'avez vu avec ce reportage
tourné en albanie par fabrice qu'une
haie on en parle avec notre invité
véronique mathieu bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes députée européenne
d'origine française ou travailler sur
les questions de justice et de sécurité
et vous êtes membre notamment de la crim
la commission spéciale sur la
criminalité organisée la corruption et
le blanchiment de capitaux
alors on vous avez regardez ce reportage
c'est assez incroyable de voir cette
forme d esclavage moderne au 21ème
siècle
est ce que finalement la lutte contre
ces réseaux criminels mais n'est pas
vaine on se dit en voyant ça que
malheureusement les trafiquants ou
toujours une longueur d'avancé sur les
états ou les ou sur les polices oui
malheureusement c'est un petit peu le
cas d'un certain nombre d'états qui
frappe d'ailleurs à la porte de l'europe
puisque vous savez que l'albanie est
candidate pour intégrer l'union
européenne et c'est un petit peu la
force que nous avons nous au sein de
l'union c'est que nous essayons de
mettre l'allemagne et au pas donc la
mafia est très présente en albanie et
nous essayons de lutter contre la mafia
avec le poste de candidate à l'union
alors quelles sont les racines du mal si
je puis dire est ce que c'est un
problème de l'état albanais qui manquent
on l'a vu des structures des moyens ou
peut-être même de la volonté politique
pour traiter ce problème ou est ce que
c'est la conséquence de la pauvreté qui
force tous et où certaines familles à
qui mais certains enfants dans les mains
des criminels
quelle est la cause de ça mais les
facteurs sont multiples il y à déjà
effectivement un manque de structures
sociales politiques de structures au
niveau de l'état bien évidemment mais il
ya aussi un problème de niveau de vie et
on sait bien les mafias se développe
quand le niveau de vie est très bas on
le voit bien d'ailleurs même au niveau
de l'union européenne en ce moment alors
que nous connaissons une crise très
importante et bien la mafia se développe
parce que les gens
on peur les gens sont dans une situation
très incertaine et la mafia est en train
de gagner du terrain un petit peu
partout alors particulièrement en
albanie parce que la mafia est très
forte elle a d'ailleurs des connexions
au niveau mondial et on vous savez bien
l'allemagne est proche de l'italie où la
mafia est très importante et la mafia
albanaise à une connexion très
importante avec la mafia italienne
est-ce que l'union européenne avec ses
moyens à la possibilité de lutter contre
ces réseaux criminels et comment oui des
jeunes on a des structures pour lutter
contre cela on a des agences européennes
par exemple europol qui est une sorte de
fbi européen qui est de plus en plus
performants parce qu'on lui donne les
moyens on a eu juste qu'ils aident qui
sont d une autre agence européenne qui
met en place des équipes comme une
enquête et on sait par exemple
qu'europol a eu des belles prises avec
qui concerne la mafia albanaise on sait
par exemple qu'à mulhouse à l'automne
dernier europol la réussite d'une belle
prise ce qui concerne la mafia albanaise
filet mais que s'il est tout à fait
parce qu'il ya une bonne connexion qui
est organisé par 1re pole
donc bon c'est on a des résultats
concrets mais ça n'est encore pas
suffisant on ne peut pas tout réussir un
coup mais est ce que vous pensez pas que
ce pour lutter contre ce problème ça
passe aussi par des actions de
prévention sur le terrain par exemple
même dans l'est dans les camps de
réfugiés mais on sait que les
trafiquants profitent des des situations
de conflits de pour asseoir leur emprise
sur les plus faibles
il faut le faire mais pour cela bien sûr
on à la difficulté de la prévention
alors il faudrait qu'on puisse être
présent partout les ong on l'a vu
l'offre reportages font évidemment un
travail de terrain un travail de fourmi
qui est extrêmement important et ça
passe aussi par l'éducation des enfants
on espère qu'avec cette cette prévention
par l'éducation évidemment la mafia va
reculer un petit peu mais c'est sûr
vraiment du très long terme
ça c'est clair très long terme c'est à
quel horizon prendre les petits vous le
voyez bien très petit alors en éduquant
les gamins on espère que ça va reculer
mais c'est ce que tous les pays
européens jouent le jeu
s'il ya une prise de conscience de tous
les pays européens par rapport à cette
préoccupation
on parle bien ici de traite des êtres
humains et on est au 20e siècle la
traite des êtres humains c'est vraiment
on le sent une spécialisation un petit
peu dans la mafia les mafias qui sont
présentes en albanie les mafias dans les
balkans ça on le constate très nettement
l'impression rien ce reportage que
l'état albanais jouent le jeu on a vu
que l'europe était présente sur place on
a un petit bureau des petits moyens on
n'a pas l'impression que le lait-
albanel la suivent si je puis dire
l'état albanais soit vraiment intégrer
l'union européenne et ça va être la
condition sine qua none on a mis on a
mis les conditions drastiques pour
l'intégration elle d'ailleurs l'albanie
n'a encore pas son statut de candidate
on a mis un certain nombre de douze
points très importants sur les questions
sociales des questions de démocratie des
questions de criminalité organisée ça
c'est une question sur laquelle le
conseil ne cédera pas et on va voir si
les si les résultats
et si le et si la volonté de l'état
albanais n'est pas au rendez-vous et
bien le conseil ne cédera pas sur le
statut de candidat après le syndic
candidats il y à l'intégration à l'union
donc vous voyez c'est un chemin qui est
très long et il aura le tout l'état
albanais aura le temps de progresser
dans sa lutte contre la criminalité
organisée
particulièrement la traite des êtres
humains la traite est la prostitution
des êtres humains
après il ya le trafic de drogue au seuil
d'un trafic de drogue également la mafia
albanaise est malheureusement très en
pointe aussi avec des connexions vers
les pays européens mais également
les états unis et vers le sud aussi de 2
vers l'afrique également on vous dit que
cette forme d'exploitation sont en
hausse au coeur même de l'ofppt de
l'émir au coeur même de l'europe
tout à fait on sait par où ce qui passe
par la grèce par l'italie donc ses
défauts malheureusement avec des
frontières qui ne sont nos frontières
européennes qui sont encore par
suffisamment bien bien et c'est aussi ça
lui de des quiz
merci beaucoup véronique mathieu d'avant
était avec nous pour commenter ce
reportage c'est la fin de cette émission
je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine à bruxelles avec françois
beaudonnet d'ici là très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires